[Music]  hello hey my friend I got that kid I was  talking to you about him I'm gonna put  him on the phone let you talk them okay  oh yes are you Frank this is Jimmy Hoffa  let's meet you glad to meet you too even  if it's over the phone our friends speak  true I hear you thank you only three  people in the world and one of these and  only one of them is Irish  I heard you paint houses yes I do so  where are you going  go to work well you know what it is a  situation going on now Frank  big business and the government they're  trying to pull us down you might be  demonstrating a failure to show  appreciation I knew things they don't  know why not  you can't miss the big picture sooner or  later  everybody could hear as a date he's  gonna go  you want to be a part of this fight  would you like to be a part of this  history yes I would  whatever you need me to do I'm available  he likes the tuft on  [Music]